I tweeted for fun for the first time in
a while yesterday
and it's like actually doing well and
it's so stupid what'd you say because
you know there's a whole discussion
about like the people getting like the
reaction of the Pfizer vaccine yeah yeah
yeah I just said Pfizer dummy dude some
of them that [__] was actually funny the
other Pfizer got me yanking my meat
aggressively
that was good I laughed at that all
right that's fair I just you know I was
crying at one it was like this like
[__] little Latino Kid like dancing
he's hitting that what dance move is
that even hard as hell I I think he's
just you know I think he's just teasing
that he's about to get busy how many he
does yeah when he lets him finally here
yeah dude
yo we're gonna get copyrighted as hell
for that all right I'll take it back
this song definitely makes it funnier
Rogelio 25 a healthcare worker was
mandated to take five
let's go with 19 vaccine three days
later paralyzed from legs down followed
by severe convulsions and seizures can
no longer clean cook drive a car
requires full-time caretaker I'm a
prisoner in my own home and that's and
that's the video yes there really are
just painfully stupid people online
right now
that are really confident
did you did you being chronically online
is starting to become like a legitimate
disease
yeah
I can't wait for the day man when
doctors start pulling in 26 year olds
and or no no we're just gonna get those
uh cookie cutter
uh Pharma ads are you chronically online
you may have chronic energy you know
yeah you may have you might have chronic
Chicken brain
yeah chronic somethingitis yeah you know
and then they just it they just Rebrand
[__] Klonopin
it takes 600 grams of Klonopin to reduce
your amount of online and just show
someone comatose in their bedroom
and the graph of screen time going down
yeah
the longer you're unconscious the longer
your screen time goes down
the amount of people that [__] tagged
me in the in this moose running into the
car video oh bro
that one wasn't even that good I mean
it's not that good it's just anything
that involves any sort of moose or deer
or elk or anything yep we get tagged in
it like relentlessly yeah this one
wasn't you know
it didn't really do anything for me
I mean he he charged full speed yeah but
dude I kind of do I think in the realm
of animals getting punted you know yeah
we're we're Beyond you know like the
doggy style you know what I mean
you know when people watch porn too much
they gotta just go to the depths they
gotta watch yeah yeah we're like we've
Advanced yeah we we're at you know we're
desensitized yeah bury me in a hole in a
rubber suit that's where we're at with
moose hunting
someone posted that too I think oh man I
saw it was like maybe on the on my
Reddit or something like that but
somebody was like I remember Cody and
Noel like help me find this video please
I remember Cody Noelle joking about
someone being uh like lowered into a
hole in the ground and then covered
this is so funny reading about someone
trying to find that video like they're
like I need to see this so bad that I'm
gonna post on Reddit
and then someone was like steamy tweets
oh my God yeah
dude I remember being so gassed to play
that because I I just knew this is gonna
be the weirdest thing ever should we run
it back right now Luke's got it up yeah
sure
is this is this the one yeah okay yeah
that's that's our that's our guy right
there
a guy with a hole in his living room
oh yeah House of gourd oh [__] lots of
gourd hey man by the way those are the
carpets we we could put in our gym this
dude looks just like like the most
normal like middle class
dad ever what if he's not actually into
it only the lady is and he just is he's
just a former like construction
contractor that knows how to do this an
engineer exactly she's like will you
build me a hole that you could bury me
into he's like ah yeah I suppose look at
him look at the way he's lowering
virtual the foundation is structurally
sound enough do you know what this what
what this built on is it is it soot or
is it
Granite is it Bedrock if it's Bedrock I
could get through it in about a week you
know if we're
you know uh
uh and and even anything anything softer
than that I would not advise building it
here we should we should probably do it
out back
I can build you a little elevator in
there if you want I mean go back look at
the way he lowers her he just
he treats it like a pallet at Home Depot
now go to the to go like 10 more seconds
back
like the way he gets his hand on it look
at that yeah yeah now it just be a
second we just get right in there
foreign
you go there
um
so let me know when you want to come
back up
and I'll just be right here I'm watching
I got this game I got my pager right
here so you know how to contact me
those Adam just has a sandwich somewhere
hey Gord hey how you doing
my wife my wife packed me lunch again
today
so what you got today ask some lady just
want me to put her in a hole Yeah
I go back there about an hour and you
know I I pull her out
he's like are you sure you want to do
this because this is going to do you
know it'll it'll damage your rug
the way he's got the two-piece rubber
mat over it
now see if you cut it in two pieces it
it'll give it a little bit better grip
so uh the disc won't float as much
yep okay how
how could you possibly
be turned on by this you know I don't I
don't mean like fetish shame or anything
but I I
this is that's a big question mark for
me
there is ah just unwinding after
uh
day's honest work you know yep put a
woman in a hole I think I think that's
the Kink is uh
you know you're enslaved to someone
and I think the other way around is like
you get off on being the master
I like it as it posted on our
claustrophobia
what else we got on this subreddit yeah
why would are these people that are
claustrophobic because if they are why
would they want
irrational fear my ass okay
yeah what what is the point why would
you want to see this if you're
claustrophobic you know oh it's this
that's the point of the subreddit it's
to I guess exposure therapy Maybe
this is just going to be a cat
yeah I don't know why cats do this cats
are stupid as [__] God that's awesome
I have the parasite dude I absolutely
100 have it why because you want to go
on a fishbowl
no no I don't want to become a cat I'm
just [__] obsessed with my cats now I
like I don't know I don't know what
happened oh
and every time I see a video of a cat
I'm like I like my endorphins start
firing